استاذ الارشيف العثماني في كم كبير من
الوثائق وخاصه وثائق المنطقه العربيه
الارشيف العثماني لم يصنف منه الان الا
سوى 35% وياخذون عينات
في حين نسبه 65% من الوثائق ومحتويات
الارشيف العثماني ما زالت مجهوله بالنسبه
حتى للاتراك وباء الباحث غير
وهذه الوثائق تحتوي كنوز من المعلومات
وخاصه في تاريخ الجزيره العربيه زي
المعلومه
خريطه عثمانيه
رسمت او وضعت سنه 1211 للهجره وهي الخريطه
العسكريه التي هاجم بها ابراهيم باشا
الدرعيه قبل لا يحاصر الدرعيه اعتمد او
هذه الخريطه هذه الخريطه هذه اللغه
العثمانيه هذه الخريطه وضعت على زمن حمل
الطوسون باشا حمله ابراهيم باشا التي فشلت
وانهزمت في
الخريطه هذه الخريطه تبين
خريطه عسكريه
اهميتها تبين ان قوات ابراهيم باشا كانت
تتمركز في هذه المنطقه واول حي هاجمه حي
الطريف وهو الان الموجود في قصور سلوى ثم
حي البجيري والان في ساريه علم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وهذا على ما يبدو انه الطريق الان الذي
يمثل طريق الملك خالد طريق الملك خالد
وهذا تقريبا
بالمكان هذا تقريبا عسكره ابراهيم باشا
عسكر بها قوات ابراهيم باشا كان تعسكر
بهذه المنطقه وهذا تصنيف الوثيقه وهي
رقمها في رقمها في الارشيف العثماني وفي
صوره محفوظه في منها في مكتبه الباحث
السعودي يعقوب برشيد دغيثر نعم نعم وهذه
خريطه عسكريه وجدت في الارشيف وجدت في
الارشيف حتى شوف مكتوب فيها هنا هي ما زال
العثمانيه
قبل الطويجري وحيا طريف عرفت كيف وجبل
زهره وهذه هي وثيقه عثمانيه